which is uh it's very similar if you
attended our meetups before
so welcome everyone to this 27th pi data
cambridge meetup
this is our january meetup our first one
of the year
and as has been for this past month we
are fully online
so the agenda today we have one talk and
it's from alexei
mikhailuk i hope i said that correctly
and it's about active learning scaling
and data set merging for ranking and
trading surveys
in image quality assessment
this is the only talk we will have today
and we are kind of trialling
having only one talk instead of two
maybe
maybe people prefer since there is a
little bit of soon fatigue i know i know
it myself
i get a bit tired after a whole day of
zoom meetings
so we're trying one talk please let us
know any feedback
if you think this is a good idea and you
rather have something like this
great uh another reminder this is being
recorded and we are already recording
so who we are so we're the local meetup
chapter of cambridge uk
pineda cambridge we started in november
2018
we do monthly meetups every last
wednesday of the month and it's
organized by me
federico joris uh leandro and ole
and just to remind you that we do this
as volunteers
um we uh uh so it just surrounds this uh
volunteering essentially we are just
volunteers
um so yeah we are supported by noon
focus which
supports pi data which is really an
educational program of new noon focus so
all the beat ups conferences that you
might be familiar with
the youtube channel it's all thanks to
noom focus
num focus has a lot of projects that it
supports many open source projects
many of them you might be using like
personally you know using
pandas a lot uh would using you jupiter
matlab my lab etc and yeah
they support these projects that we all
use uh
and support this meetup itself too
so please consider donating to noon
focus you can go
donate all year there's some donation
drives but you can always donate
at any point you can do a recurring
donation at all types of things so
please consider doing that
we also like to remind you that in this
meetup we have a code of conduct which
is a pi data code of conduct
the general idea is that you have to
behave professionally this is a
professional environment
uh so any so essentially no harassment
no sexist or racist or
exclusionary joke jokes uh
and we have a response team for the
conduct which is
all the organizers so you can always
contact us
if you think there has been a breach is
the code of conduct
and if you wouldn't rather contact
someone that is not part of
the organizers but as a representative
a separate representative an independent
representative of the response team you
can contact
leonie
we are always looking for more speakers
uh to present in the 2021 agenda
uh and uh and and i think the donation
drive to non-focus is still open
that last point is already from a
different uh meetup i forgot to delete
that i'm sorry
uh but yeah we're always looking for
speakers if you are having an
interesting
talk an interesting topic please uh
email us or contact us or just mention
it in the in the
in the message chat here in the in zoom
we would also like to talk thanks to our
sponsors which is
arm fetch ai num focus itself and
raspberry pi
which supported us when we were an
in-person meetup they supported us
this whole time since we were we started
so we
we still consider them our sponsors and
hopefully we will remain with them
uh our sponsors can support us with many
things like zoom licenses
meetup fees etc when we're in person we
can we can sponsor people traveling
great so from arm which is where i work
and where leandro works to solve our
organizers we have some positions
some data positions like data principle
data engineer graduate data engineer
data data analyst and a senior
performance analysis
engineer some of these are some of these
positions are unfamiliar
to me but we i'm always happy to discuss
and talk about these positions
if you're interested in applying we are
hiring in a lot of other positions
uh so please do take a look
from raspberry pi we we just wanted to
highlight that they have
uh weekly live streams with educational
activities
i think these are still ongoing about
doing digital making at home
please just check the raspberry pi
website for any activities that they're
up to
uh our sponsor is fetch ai they have a
lot of
uh updates for us they've built some
applications framework to enable hotel
operators to deploy autonomous ai travel
engines
agents to market uh so you should really
take a look at what
fetch ai is doing you can also join
their discord
if you'd like to have a discussion with
them and
and if you want to collaborate with them
you can contact them directly
great so i did say if you are interested
in
in in speaking please contact us how can
you do this well you can contact us
either twitter or email but
we also post these recordings in the in
the youtube channel of pi data
we're always looking for sponsors so
we're always willing to discuss
and we are always looking for speakers i
will also
highlight that please do feel free to
introduce yourself in the
zoom chat what you do why why did you
end up in this meetup
anything that you would like to share
maybe you'll find someone who's
interested in the same things as you
and i'll stop now and let and let
alexa share his screen and we'll get
started
hi everyone can you hear me yeah we can
hear you okay and i can see the
presentation so i think we're
good perfect um so to start with
um my name is alexi and today i'm going
to talk about
uh probably one of the major parts of my
life uh in the past
10 years this is my phd and i'll be
discussing
the topic of active learning scaling and
data set merging for ranking and rating
surveys
i would mostly concentrate on the
examples in image quality assessment
but bear in mind throughout the whole
presentation that
those techniques that i will be
discussing today are applicable to many
many problems as you'll see also during
the presentation
so first of all a little bit about
myself
i'm currently a research assistant at
the department of computer science at
cambridge university as i mentioned i've
just finished my phd under the
supervision of dr rahul mantuck
and before that i was working with deep
learning algorithms for multidimensional
data reconstruction
also at cambridge under the supervision
of dr anita fall
and i was happy to see her in in the
audience today
i also worked on machine learning and
computer vision for pothole detection at
bristol
and the supervision of doctor named noon
so um to start off the presentation
let's
look at slightly bigger picture
there are very many applications and
image processing
that requires some sort of fine tuning
so that would be super resolution
colorization
and denoising those applications are
very common to every one of us
when we're using our smartphones there
are many different
processing stages that um camera
hardware is performing and also many
post processing
stages in the software and to develop
all those algorithms
we need some sort of tuning so we need
to know whether images
look good or not so as i mentioned
it would be nice to have fine tuning for
those algorithms
but unfortunately on many occasions
standard metrics that we are used to
such as psnr peak signal to noise ratio
are failing so in this case
psnr is greater for the left image and
much lower
not much lower but lower for the right
image although perceptually the right
image
looks much better at least to me so
we need something different the ultimate
consumer of
the digital contact or content of images
is the human
and thus we need the results to be
perceptually pleasing for him
but at the same time we cannot really
use
humans to fine-tune those algorithms
directly
because it's simply inefficient to put a
human in front of a screen
and ask them to adjust the parameters of
the algorithm
until he or she finds the perfection
so it would be nice to find the model of
human judgments for image quality
so that we can use automated algorithms
to fine-tune
those image processing algorithms but we
run into the same problem
to fine-tune those models we need human
judgments and collecting those
is very expensive as i said it would be
pretty difficult to
put humans in front of this screen and
ask them to um
compare or get get get the notion of
their
quality judgment um simply because it's
very expensive
and time consuming as well so for that
we need
methods that would uh facilitate this
process of collecting human judgments
let's sidestep again and look at the
full pipeline for image and video
processing and then i'll discuss every
step in more details
so we start with the criteria that would
be either
quality of the image something that we
would be judging or aesthetic
of the image for example if we were
thinking about photoshop
we need to have an image that as
aesthetically pleasing might not be of
the best quality
we can also look at the visibility of
the distortions in the image
or realism if you are talking about
generative
adversarial networks or generally tip
models in general
um would be nice to have them produce
images that are realistic enough
we then look into subjective
image quality so how to elicit those
human judgments
according to the criteria that we've
selected before would it be quality of
images
aesthetics or visibility generate two
types of experiments and distinguish
ranking and rating
we then use the scores that we collect
in those subjective experiments
to fine-tune objective image quality
matrix as i mentioned those automated
models that
model human judgments and after that we
can use the feedback from those models
to fine-tune image processing algorithms
so let's talk a little bit about
different criteria that we've seen just
now
first of all we can think about
aesthetics of the image
so we need algorithms to produce images
that are aesthetically pleasing
we would be thinking about the image at
the top and the bottom
and whether the top one or the bottom
one are more is more aesthetically
pleasing for example for my subjective
judgments i
very much like the noisy image at the
top simply because it has
some atmosphere in it but from the
side of quality it's probably not the
best option
we can then look at the quality
assessment a different criteria
here we would be judging the quality of
the test image which is on the right
with respect to the reference image
which is on the left
and clearly here the test image is
visibly worse than
the reference image finally if we're
talking again about quality visibility
and aesthetics assessment of images
the last criteria is visibility where
we want to figure out what parts of the
image
have noticeable artifacts in them
and here for example observer human
observer
might choose areas somewhere in the lake
or at the bushes
pointing to them saying that those are
areas for which algorithm has not
produced a good job
so as i mentioned today in the
presentation i will be mostly
concentrating on image quality
assessment
um how do those data sets that contain
human judgments for image quality
assessment look like
and this is a perfect example of that
for you in in the
in the slide usually there would be
images that would be
mapped to the quality score that is
collected from human observers and here
for example you can see the reference
image that is completely perfect and
then
images decrease in their quality as we
can see by the quality scores that are
obtained from human observers
and then image quality assessment models
objective image quality assessment
models automated models
would take an image as an input and try
to reproduce the subjective square
obtained from the human
observer i will talk about those models
in more details
later in the presentation
i should stop here for a bit and
sidestep from image quality assessment
and mentioned that the method that i
will be listing
further in the presentation are very
applicable to many many problems
not only image quality assessment so
we're talking here about scale inference
how to infer the scale
of the quality for images in my case or
for example many other applications such
as education
for example this year we had or last
year we had a massive problem with
gcc results where we had to map somehow
the
performance of the students across
different schools so that
they can get to university and this is
also the problem of scale inference
we can also think about customer
satisfaction how to infer the scale for
products such as headphones or similarly
sports
games where we want to have players
that ranking tables of the players such
as chess or tennis tournaments
we can also think about the scale for
realism as i mentioned generative models
or image quality assessment
something that i'm returning back now
so how to elicit human judgments this is
the general question that
that is being addressed in in scale
inference
so there are two different methods
one method is rating where we ask
observers to rate
images um on a scale either continuous
or discrete
so here for example we can ask um how
good is
the in the first case how good is the
image on the scale from one to one
hundred
or similarly on on the second example we
can
ask them to put the image in one of the
categories
another kind of experiments that we can
use to elicit human judgments
is comparative judgment or previous
comparisons similarly they can call
it can be called ranking so
here there are many different examples
of
of um how we can elicit this ranking or
comparative judgment
we can either compare images side by
side or ask observers to order them
in the order of quality or cluster them
together so put
similar in quality images together
i should stop here and mention that for
rating it's pretty straightforward to
obtain the
quality score corresponding to the image
if you think about it if we
ask um 10 or 15 observers to rate
a single image then we can easily say
that mean observer score
is just the average of this course and
then we can also find the uncertainty in
the
observer's judgment by finding the
standard deviation of the
observer judgments that we elicit for
this
for this image we can then do some
post-processing
to remove observer bias but still the
process is pretty straightforward
the bigger question is how can we map
the purpose comparisons so those
discrete judgments about
image quality to one dimensional scale
and this is something that i'm going to
talk about now
so how can we scale pairwise comparisons
first thing
i will talk here about the most general
model that is usually used for
scaling previous comparisons that is
commonly used by microsoft in trueskill
or in many economics studies called this
model is also called thurston model
so for that we model um
quality scores as normal distributions
with mean and standard deviation
in the most simple case we have a fixed
standard deviation for
all for all scores
now probably question to all of you
is how can we map those previous
comparisons that we collect
so the binary outputs of one condition
or image being selected over
another image to the probability of one
being better inferred from the quality
scores
so give you just a second here
before i give an answer and
simple thing to do is to find the
difference between the two
and luckily enough since we're working
with normal distributions
the result also will be normal
distribution
what we can do then is to find the area
under the curve
from minus infinity to 0 and that would
give us the probability
of condition b selected over a so what
part of the distribution is
on the negative side that is the
probability of of condition b being
selected over a
this is essentially the definition of
the cumulative distribution function
once we know that we can then use some
modeling
to to infer the quality scores
and here we are working with the
binomial distribution
where and and we have
several parameters so first of all we
are
obtaining the product across all pairs
of
conditions we have the probability of
the outcome inferred from the
quality scores that we are trying to
model and
this is all very nicely fits in the
binomial distribution because
we putting that into the power of number
of times
one condition was selected over another
condition and then we can use
maximum likelihood estimation to infer
this course
this is a very simple model that gives
us support estimates
there are more complex models as we see
further down
um the presentation that uh includes uh
by asian estimation of this course where
we can include
infer the whole posterior
so one of the things that i should
mention here is that it's very well
known the trunking
experiments are much more accurate than
rating experiments
but as we saw with the previous slide we
have to do this product across all
across all pairs of um conditions
so the drawback here is that for n
conditions
there are very many pairings possible
pairings so how do we select those spurs
of conditions that bring the most
information to the scale
this is the question that we're trying
to answer now
so how can we minimize this number of
comparisons performed while maximizing
the information about the scale
generally that there are two types of
methods that are distinguished sorting
based
these are based on a simple heuristic
that's similar in quality or skill pairs
conditions should be compared to each
other so images of similar quality
should be paired with each other because
it will bring us more information than
comparing
images that are far away from each other
in the scale because
comparing very poor quality image to
very good quality image doesn't make
sense because the outcome is obvious
it's much more interesting to compare
images that have
very close quality scores another type
of methods
is based on models and those are
information based
and here we are actually selecting the
pairs of
conditions that would be minimizing the
uncertainty in the scale
according to some information gain
criteria and in my phd i worked on the
method
called asap which has recently been
presented at the icpr conference for
which
we received the best paper award
so please feel free to check out the
code and the project page
that might be useful for your work as
well so
now i'll describe typical pipeline for
information gain based
methods to which the method that i have
developed also falls
so we start from various comparisons
this would be data collected so far
we then infer the scale those would be
usually the scale inferred with the full
posterior distribution instead of
likelihood estimation would then use the
scale to select the next comparison
and here we are using those information
gain metrics that
would uh choose the next perk of
comparisons to perform
then we run the experiment that would be
either game or chess tournament
or image quality assessment experiment
with a human observer
and then we update the data collected so
far
so how can we infer the full posterior
and
in my method we are using truescale
where we are interested in inferring the
score variable
normally distributed given the output
variables
those would be the outcome of the pair
base comparison
very nice thing is that we can actually
not approximate
the posterior as many methods do that
work with information gain criteria but
then for a full posterior
um gaining as much accuracy as possible
about
the infrared scores
um as i mentioned it provides the
distribution of the scores both mean and
variance
for inference we are using some product
algorithm with expectation propagation
by a moment matching
and this is used because the binary
outcome
variables are not conjugate likelihood
from the binary output variables is not
conjugate to
normal prior so we need some iterations
for more details please
check out the true scale paper so now we
are
having this scale can use expectation
information gain expected information
gain
to infer the next possible pair of
comparisons
so we start with the data collected so
far here's is the
matrix of previous comparisons where in
each
row and column we have a number and this
number is the number of times
the condition in the corresponding row
was selected over condition in the
corresponding column
so if we look at the conditions two and
three condition three was selected
one time over condition two and
condition two was selected 3 times
over condition 3. we now simulate
all possible comparison outcomes and
infer the scale for all possible
simulated comparison outcomes
after that we compare the inferred
skills for all simulated outcomes with
the original scale
in my case i'm using kl divergence
and then we can also obtain the expected
information gain by waiting by the
probability of
the comparison outcome
let's look at the example so we have
this pairwise comparison matrix
in the plot on the right we have um
the inferred scale first of all what we
do we simulate the outcome in which
condition black won blue we calculate
the kl divergence with the original
scale
and the probability of the result
probability of the result
is simply the as we saw with the maximum
likelihood
estimation is the cumulative
distribution function
of the difference between two variables
we then
go back to the original scale simulate
the outcome for blue
one black find the kill divergence also
find the probability of the results in
this case
the probability of the result for blue
winning black is higher as we can see
obviously because it's better
and then we can find the expected
information gain with this
by weighting the outcome with the
probability of the outcome
by waiting kel diversion with the
probability of of the outcome
so talking about the results um
i should mention that um in this graph
rmsc denotes the accuracy of the
method so the lower rms the more
accurate the method is and standard
trial on the x-axis
is the number of comparisons performed
so far there are three distinct classes
of methods and as you can see the
sorting based methods
perform the worse so i've shown you the
uh two different categories of methods
that can be used
then we have information gain based
methods that use approximate
um scale inference
and asap follows with the full posterior
update uh based on the true skill
with the highest accuracy so in our work
we've figured out that
it's very important to infer the most
accurate um
scale distribution to attain the highest
accuracy for active sampling
of paris comparisons so if you look at
the code
code is very simple we start with the
previous comparison matrix
then we initialize the algorithm this
code is i should mention
is is on the github so please feel free
to check it out
and then what we do is just run this up
with the previous comparison matrix
and get the pairs to compare if you are
interested in this work please feel free
to check out the paper
saying all that and working on this
method
asap during my phd i was thinking
whether it
can be possible to reuse the data that
has been collected so far from
other experiments so there are many
different data sets
with image quality that are available
that were collected before me so we
might not even need this
active sampling method to compare to
select uh to collect new data set we can
just maybe reuse the data has been
collected so far
so it would be nice to start with two
data set one data set has
image images with respect to their
quality and another data set has images
with respect to their quality
can we just somehow merge this data
together so that we have
larger data set with image quality and
then we can train more complex models
on that larger data set the short answer
to that is
actually we cannot and
one of the problems here is that
different scales and different
experimental procedures prevent from
direct merging so
one data set can be coming from various
comparisons another dataset can be
coming from
rating and how can we actually merge
them together
those have different scales one has from
for example
zero to ten another one from zero to one
hundred how can we find the
correspondence of ten
is it a hundred in a different scale or
so
this was the question that i was trying
to address in this work
um how can we merge them together
so that we maybe do as few measurements
as possible so
one thing that occurred clearly to me
that to merge those datasets
it would be nice to find those
correspondences between the
high scores lower scores and how those
data sets are aligned together
and i figured out that it would be very
difficult to
get away without any new measurements uh
performed on on the data sets so we
would need to run some
experiments to infer the relative
position of the scales
as i mentioned this is also the work
that is related to my phd please feel
free to check out the paper
and the code and i think the qr code
leads you to the
project web page so if you please feel
free to scan it
so coming back to the problem we have
two data set two data sets
in the top left corner we have a data
set that was collected from pairwise
comparisons
so it has various comparisons which is
obvious
another data set is obtained with the
rating experiments data set too
those are as we remember
distinct human judgments uh about the
quality of every image
one thing that was necessary that i
figured out was necessary is to find
the uh the relative
difference in the rating scores compared
to
previous comparison outcomes so one
thing that i had to perform for rating
data sets that i was merging with
previous comparison experiments is to
introduce various comparisons to rating
data set as well after that i also
introduced
the cross data set comparisons to align
the scales together
with all that i use the maximum
likelihood estimation procedure to
merge the scores together
so as a visual example we have a data
set score
on the y-axis let's pretend that we
don't have x-axis and we have only the
access to
the y-axis the original data set score
those data sets are obtained from rating
experiments what we do is we introduce
the pervs comparisons within the data
set
and we also introduce the previous
comparisons across the data sets
after we have those previous comparisons
we can scale the data with the procedure
that i will explain
in the next slide to obtain the true
quality that is on the x
axis so aligning the data sets together
so we need to do some modeling here
to ensure that we have the joint
model for both rating and ranking scores
so first thing is to assume some
relationship between the ground truth
scores
that we saw on the x-axis in the
previous slide and the y-axis the
original
rating score and in white work i use a
very simple
linear relationship so here we have
we assume that the rating experiment
scores are normally distributed
and they can be mapped to the ground
truth's quality square qi
with a simple linear relationship with a
and b
and this is actually not such a poor
assumption
given that um we need to have monotonic
relationship between
uh the rating scores that we obtain and
grow underlying ground truth score that
we're trying to infer
so the increase in rating score should
be reflected in the
in the increase in the ground score that
we're trying to infer
what we do then we can obtain the
probability for all
rating scores by multiplying across all
observers
and across all all all conditions in the
data set
for previous comparison we assumed the
model that was uh
used in the previous example based on
the binomial distribution
then we can use the full model which
would be just the product of the
uh various comparison model with the
rating model
and then we also multiply by prior to
ensure that the
quality scores are bounded together not
spreading out too much
in the in in the scale as i've mentioned
since we introduced those
uh previous comparisons across the
data sets and we didn't within the data
sets with ranking
we actually link all the probability
models together
so talking about the code we start with
the various comparison matrix
those would be pair of comparisons that
are collected for different data sets so
for example in this data set in in this
example would have data sets
with two different sizes having four
images and five images respectfully
um we would have entries in the previous
comparison matrix in red and blue
corresponding to two different data sets
those would be the comparisons within
the data set
and we would have also comparisons
across the data sets
in black here in mean opinion score
we would have also different sections
for different data sets
we would have in red rating scores
collected for
each individual condition for the first
data set and
in blue for a different data set um as
you can notice
in the blue data set we have one raw
missing but this is not a problem
because we have collected previous
comparison for the missing condition
in the previous comparison matrix so we
can actually infer the
underlying quality score for this
condition from the uh
from the data that we have overall from
both pairwise comparison and rating
we then use a simple method that is
included in the github
repository merge data sets provide the
previous comparisons mean opinions
course and data
sizes and we infer the parameters that
we have in our model
so having all this data that we have
collected either with
active sampling algorithms that we have
developed or
by merging multiple data sets together
having plenty a plethora of
images versus their subjective quality
scores we can train objective quality
metrics so train
some model to predict the quality score
from the
image so there are several methods that
can be used for that
first one is based on natural synth
statistics another one is based on
modeling human visual system
and finally we also have a class of
methods based on deep learning that
use automated feature extraction to
regress
to the quality score so first of all
natural scene statistics those
answers ask a simple question
what do natural images so undistorted
clean from noise images
have in common that is destroyed by
noise those are usually based on
wavelength decomposition
as we see how how it works in the next
slide
once we have the value of the
composition of the image we can
use the coefficient of this the
composition as features which we then
use to regress to the quality score
those usually do not need any reference
image so we can just pass a test image
to those
natural scenes statistic based image
quality models
that would give us the quality score
this is to contrast it with the
full reference methods that would need
also the
undistorted image reference image passed
with the test image and we would find
the
distance between the two as i i'll show
for different
class of methods so what we have here
is valid decomposition those are
simple basis function and we actually
can decompose
images into different kinds of wavelets
and
probably the simplest example that
everyone encountered
and in school or in early years of the
universities
free decomposition those would be simple
decomposition to the cosine and
sine basis functions once we compose the
image into those
we can use the coefficients as i
mentioned as features
so here for example we would be
decomposing an image at different scales
in the decomposition coefficients are
features
we use often use those methods use
natural statistics methods use pca to
reduce
dimensionality because there are many
coefficients not all of them are useful
once we perform the pca we can then
regress to the score many methods use
either svms or perceptrons to to regress
to the quality score
so here we have three images um original
image undistorted by noise
image with white noise and blurry image
now we can see
the coefficients for one bend of the
wavelets and we can clearly see that
those have very different distributions
so there can be actually something that
we can find to to regress to the quality
score
another kind of methods is based on
modeling human visual system
those aren't ask a question can we use
uh model early stages of human vision to
figure out what human eye picks up
as something undistorted in the image
how can we distinguish with our early
stage vision as having having some
distortions or not having distortions
so those are usually white box models um
and two very good examples of those
models are
hdr vdp very popular metric and fsim
also very popular method usually as i've
mentioned to contrast it to
the natural scene statistic based
methods this is our full reference where
we are supplying both
the test image and reference image to
the metric
and then find some discrepancy between
the two
so one of the things that we can use is
contrast sensitivity
function not sure if many of you are
familiar with that but
it is a function that tells us whether
we can
see the variations in the frequency
under different contrast
and generally humans have this curve
shown on the left
where some variations are more visible
for the lower
spatial frequency and some variations
are less visible under different
contrast
we can then include that information
that some of the frequencies will be
masked given some contrast
in the quality matrix so that we can
emit some parts of the image where the
contrast is masked
this is a simple example where we feed
reference in the signal and distorted
signal
do some pre-processing csf filtering
contrast sensitivity function filtering
where we as i mentioned we mask parts of
the signal
and do not take into it into account
when we are computing the
quality score and then can do some
post-processing stitches to to get get
the final quality score
there is final class of method that is
based on deep learning
those are usually black box models um
often ends to end throttle
train but unlike other methods that i've
described they need
a lot of data to be trained and this is
actually
one of the biggest problems in image
quality assessment as i mentioned
collecting this data is very
expensive since we cannot we can but
it's very time consuming for a human to
sit in front of the screen and
press one or another for
one image being better than another so
um
those are just gaining popularity when
we're starting to see
much larger data sets in image quality
assessment
they usually use standard cnns
convolution neural networks as the base
usually pre-trained and then fine-tuned
for image quality assessment tasks
so having all that let's see how they
compare to each other
i test all metrics that i will you will
show the performance of
on the tid 2013 data set it was one of
the largest data sets when i
started my phd three years ago it
contains 3000 images
with with respect with their
corresponding human observer judgments
i use sperm and front order correlation
coefficient to report
the accuracy of the comparative methods
and generate the higher coefficient the
better
and i should also mention here that no
reference metrics
were not tested on all the data set but
only on the specific distortions because
as we've seen um we need to um
or we have to with with current methods
to
be very specific to distortions that
we're trying to address with those
natural scene statistics because
different different distortions
introduced
she changed the composition coefficients
differently
so what we can see here are the
performance
results blue are full reference metrics
those are deep learning based
and those based on modeling human visual
system to some extent
tested on the full data set and there is
also a
subset given in red those are no
reference methods tested on the subset
of of distortions and as we can see
deep learning based methods actually
attain the best performance even though
many of them are trained with
quite small data sets
so having all those metrics where can
they be used we're coming back to the
first slide of my presentation
we can use it for performance evaluation
of image processing methods
so those that would be either denoising
the blurring super resolving the image
we can also use it as an objective as a
loss function for image processing
algorithms
either as end to end loss if it's
differentiable
or as a feature extractor or
similarly it's very common now to use it
as a regularization for
uh generative model training because
essentially we want
the produce results to be also
perceptually pleasing
not only realistic
so with all that i would like to wrap up
my presentation
thank you very much for your attention
um for
further links and questions please feel
free to
message me i have github repository that
is mine we also have
rainbow group github repository that is
um for the cambridge university rainbow
group at the computer
lab uh so there is quite a lot of useful
code pieces there as well there is my
email and also medium account i
try to publish regularly there as well
thank you very much are there any
questions or
is there any in this format of
discussion
yeah let's let's see if there's any
questions i do have one to start us off
um are there any uh let's say
is there any plans on on collecting more
data
since the deep learning uh methods seem
to be quite
well performing i'm assuming the more
the more data they get the
better they will get is there any um
anything planned to collect more data of
this time
definitely not by me but there are many
works that
are evolving we're evolving in the in in
the past few years maybe two years
that were addressing larger and larger
scale data sets so the data said that i
have shown the performance of
quality metrics td 2013 had only 3000
images
and now we have data sets with 10
000 images those are usually collected
with amazon mechanical turk
but again thinking about the cost it's
very costly to
collect this data there as well so
methods that i've described here are
also useful
for for collecting the data large data
sets there as well
so i think that's that the problem is
being addressed but gradually
yeah cool yeah are there any other
questions please write them in the q
a window
[Music]
yeah i think i can go one more while
people
type their questions yeah
go ahead okay so uh so i noticed that
um your examples were mostly with uh
kind of photos or kind of pictures like
like that so how do you think the
results you you got here can
kind of be transferred to other types of
images that have different uh kind of
i assume features like paintings for
example
or drawings and stuff like that do you
think they
they would generalize enough to capture
the particularities of different classes
of images
i would say uh i would say no here you
if you mean the image quality assessment
methods that yes
so those are mostly used for
natural images so for paintings i would
imagine there
would be needed some aesthetics
measurements
that would tell whether a and a painting
is aesthetically pleasing or not
uh so those methods that i have
mentioned they are not very good on
those
kind of tasks those are for impairment
assessment so how much is the image
distorted by
different kinds of noise
oh i see yep thanks
okay so yeah last chance to get some
questions in before we
finish i think alexei
there's a question in the q a um
here i'll read it out here you talk
about people ranking the quality of
whole images
but i am wondering if similar methods
could be applied to detection tasks
for example in crowdsourcing
applications when people tag
features in a data set but the labels
may vary depending on their subjective
interpretation
so those kind of methods that i
described here
those are not addressing this issue but
there are very many methods that take
that into account
including observer how reliable are
observers were
participants of the experiment um but to
answer this question shortly
the methods that i presented here they
do not address that but there are many
other methods that do address that and
if you're interested please email me i
have
a bunch of papers to share with you
cool thank you um
so right one any other questions
uh one more why do we use wavelet
transform while we can use
the image using any transform
that's that's a very good question so
essentially there were many works that
attempted different
combinations so if you're if you're
talking about
any different transform i'm not quite
sure what um what the
the question is referring to but
different kinds of wavelets have been
tried on this
image example uh for example
good the composition would be gabor
decomposition which is known to be
um naturally inspired where we have
those uh very similar um gabor viva
decomposition
going on in in the brain when we are
looking at the images so
there is actually quite a lot of
research into how to efficient
into how efficiently we can decompose
the image with different
basis function or different transforms
to listen those statistics
if that answers the question yeah
we'll see um
uh yeah another question uh yeah of
course so krish was the last question
says thanks a lot
another question just a question on the
human judgments what sort of background
did these
participants have so
that's a very good question generally
in in the experiments that i have
conducted myself
those would be my uh phd peers
phd students that would be uh
studying with me uh but if we're talking
about some amazon mechanical turk
collected data sets the observers can
have very different backgrounds if we
are talking about much larger data sets
with image quality
then there is very little control as we
know with
amazon mechanical talk about who is uh
who is
looking at the images
great i say we can have maybe a couple
more questions and there's still
more i'll wait for a few seconds
okay i think we don't have any more
questions so
thank you alexei this was a great talk
and hopefully you found the
questions and interaction interesting uh
we'll be posting this image
that this image this video very soon on
the youtube channel so you can share it
with any of your colleagues friends
and please promote pi data cambridge
thanks alexey
thank you very much
thank you everyone